We'll use story understanding,
To examine the general
processes of understanding.
Here are two stories that we
have encountered earlier.
The first story is talking about the
earthquake that hit lower Slabovia and
caused some damage.
The second story is talking about the
President of lower Slabovia who killed
a number of proposals.
Both of them deal with killing.
But the meaning of the two
stories are very, very different.
Humans make use of stories to
understand the world around them.
The world offers a very large
amount of data at any given time.
We use the stories to provide
structure to that data,
to make coherent sense of it.
When we discuss these
two stories earlier,
using frame as a knowledge
representation language,
we found that we could have
a frame of this notion of killing,
killing of 25 people, and this notion
of killing, killing of 25 proposals.
And there was no simple way in
the frame knowledge representation
to disambiguate between those
two meanings of killing.
Now we'll examine how we can construct
a different interpretation of
the first story, or
the interpretation of the second story,
based on different interpretations of
the word killing in the two stories.
In order to make the two
stories simpler, and
to illustrate our point, we're going to
focus on one sentence from each story,
sentences that contain the word kill.
Humans that have lived
through difficulty and
understanding the first sentence means
completely different from the second
sentence because the killed in the first
sentence means something completely
different from the killed
in the second sentence.
How can we build an err program
that can do the same thing?
We will see that err program will need
to use a lot of background knowledge in
order to be able to do that, and
that would generate hypotheses about
how humans might be using that
background knowledge to similarly
disambiguate between different
senses of the word killed.